we continue our trip to Southern
California thanks to the sponsors of
this segment visit Anaheim Jillian takes
us inside the house of the Retro future
themed Suites over at the Howard Johnson
Anaheim
welcome to the Future The House of the
Retro future that is we are here at the
Howard Johnson in Anaheim and I cannot
wait to show you around this Suite but I
need a little help getting a tour so I'm
joined by the general manager Jonathan
thank you so much for having us you're
welcome I feel like I am transported in
time when I come through the doors tell
us a little bit about the inspiration of
The Suite well the suite was inspired by
the original Monsanto House of the
future that was featured at Disneyland
in the 50s and 60s so we tried to
recreate that that feeling that that
style with the suite yeah and you guys
don't spare anything from the the curved
couches to the pillows to the table to
the chairs everything is really well
thought out right yep and something that
I am eyeing over here this is maybe my
favorite part of the room you have a
real record player yes and with real
finals under there real uh curated
selection of uh uh period appropriate
music yes I love it it really sets the
vibe while you're in the room and also I
cannot stop looking at the artwork on
the wall tell us about that it's shag so
uh the artist Josh eagle or better known
as shag and uh he created this artwork
and it's a family in the house of the
future featured in this house of the
future Suite oh my gosh how cool is that
all right let's keep walking because
there's more to see throughout our tour
in this week tell us about this room in
here obviously it's the it's the bedroom
and attaches the bathroom so we took
some Liberties in the bedroom because we
we saw that the original House of the
future was not really designed for a
family as a hotel so we wanted to really
just create that that feeling of the
mid-century style and the googie
architecture of the 60s and so this is
what we came up with well and speaking
of families you guys are truly right
across the street from Disneyland you
can walk right over this is a great
place for families to stay and in
addition to this really cool Suite you
also have a variety of rooms some of
which have been renovated right so a
little something for everyone and those
rooms are great for families they're
large rooms and they also have this kind
of mid-century vibe to them well I think
what anyone sees this room they're going
to want to stay here and I have been
eyeing you even have an orange phone
back there and that's authentic right it
is authentic yeah how fun is it for you
to have this themed Suite here and what
do people saying about it so far it's
been a lot of fun and people just that
have stayed or visited when they walk in
the room and you just see that that
feeling that comes over them that
they've transported themselves to uh
that earlier time that's just really
neat it's so much fun I love seeing
every little thing throughout the room
and even in the bathroom there's
something hidden which I'm not going to
tell you exactly what it is because you
got to come here to see it for yourself
the lights around every corner oh I love
that well Jonathan thank you so much for
giving us this tour this Suite is so
cool you definitely want to check it out
and I think it's time I think we got to
crank up that record player what do you
say let's go check it out time to play
some tunes Jonathan thank you so much